poire mais d'abord l'évocation de ce
film la recherche des plaisirs et des
sensations fortes la quête
obsessionnelle d'un paradis une parabole
sur la société d'aujourd'hui
nicole cornu langlois jean pierre
pasteur
1km tel rachat
j'ai passé américain
photo maël cependant km si un journal
dans notre destinée c'est qu'on saura
jamais
et c'est ainsi que leonardo le plus
célèbre naufragés de l'histoire du
cinéma
stimulé par nos deux françaises virginie
et guillaume se jette à l'eau et
débarque sur une île paradisiaque de la
thaïlande pour l' aventure de la plage
présenté dans l'hystérie collective au
festival de berlin
par là on peut descendre
moi je dis qu'en fait ceci on ne saute
pas arrête de dire n'importe quoi
mais quoi qu'on me sorte de deux
descentes c'est une idée de fond alors
toute la gamme
tous les ingrédients sont réunis pour
créer l'événement comme en témoigne la
conférence de presse avec toute l'équipe
dont leonardo dicaprio qui évoque son
personnage il est à la recherche
d'expériences forte et aussi ce qui me
fascinait dans ce personnage
sans avoir la prétention de parler pour
ma génération c'est que je me sentais
très proche de cette quête de la sagesse
celle que l'on rêve d'atteindre
l'histoire étant tourné sous la
direction du sulfureux danny boyle on se
doute vite que le trio idyllique va se
déchirer les rivalités vont naître la
vie communautaire tourner au désastre
la jalousie c'est par les amis c'était
vraiment je t'assure je sais pas de quoi
tu parles tout le monde et où chacun se
construit soi même ce qu'on a envie de
ce dont on a envie ce qu'on aime et tout
ça et c'est pas parce qu'on est dans un
endroit sublime qu'on va être forcément
heureux
telle pourrait être la morale de ce
conte exotiques dans lequel le paradis
devient descente aux enfers mais nos
trois acteurs eux sortent gagnants de
cette histoire